even the most casual viewers of the
office know that the American series
didn't begin with an original idea it's
a remake inspired by a British show by
the same name this original series run
from 2001 to 2003 and focused on the
fictional Paper Company wernham hog in
the British town of slow the American
show takes place in Scranton
Pennsylvania but it still has a
connection to its British cousin's
Hometown in the season 5 episode blood
drive Michael pulls together a
depressing little Valentine's Day
shindig for all of his single co-workers
harboring secret hopes that he will be
able to reconnect with the woman he met
earlier in the day as he shows off the
flyer he's created for the event the
camera Zooms in revealing that the
address for Dunder Mifflin is 1725 slau
Avenue the address seems to be a nod to
the location of the original wornham hog
Paper Company it's not a onetime
incident either in the last episode of
season 6 Dwight refers to the street by
name again I want you to make an offer
at 1725 slow
Avenue make them an offer they can't
refuse